bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
kiosques que votre émission culturelle
sur saint quentin en yvelines et ses
environs tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mercredi 13 avril du bistrot belge à la
vie d'artiste à paris joffrey verbruggen
nous entraîne dans son univers marginal
et décadent révélé par ses personnages
décalés dans le before du grand journal
sur canal+
l'artiste présente aujourd'hui son
premier spectacle liberté il sera là
royal factory de versailles vendredi et
samedi prochains en utilisant
essentiellement de la photographie de
paysage bertrand flash au photographe
plasticien prolonge numériquement les
branches des brindilles pour
démultiplier la nature à l'infini il
expose à la médiane il de l'hôtel de
ville de guyancourt jusqu'au 7 mai
prochain et catherine adjointe au maire
de voisins-le-bretonneux délégué à la
culture et en plateau pour nous parler
de la 7e biennale de la sculpture de la
ville
professionnels et amateurs exposent
leurs oeuvres en 3d à la maison de
covile jusqu'au 17 avril
et je vous le disais il sera à la royale
factory de versailles vendredi et samedi
prochain 15 et 16 avril
joffrey verbruggen jeune comédien belge
de 27 ans vous l'avez découvert dans le
before du grand journal sur canal+ en
2013 la même année il écrivait son
spectacle liberté
récompensé par le prix du jury lors du
dinar comedy festival et le prix du
public au festival du rire de mâcon nous
sommes allés rencontrer ce jeune artiste
joffrey verbruggen bonjour bonjour et
merci d'accepter de répondre à nos
questions les rues de vous retrouver ici
à paris alors pour vous introduire vous
êtes belge il avait 27 ans vous tournez
en ce moment avec votre premier
spectacle que vous
avait intitulé liberté que vous avez
créé en 2013 que vous avez totalement
écrit oui c'est ça c'est un spectacle
que j'ai mis que j'ai écrits etc et mis
en scène par morgan perez donc justement
vous serez à la royale factory à
versailles vendredi et samedi prochain
15 et 16 avril ça donc on va revenir sur
votre parcours vous avez démarré en tant
qu'acteur à 16 ans oui mais surtout on
vous craignez pour votre rôle principal
que vous avez tenus à 18 ans dans la
régate de bernard bellefroid pour lequel
d'ailleurs vous avez un magritte donc
ses armes edge en tant que espoir
masculin et puis alors la révélation en
2013 c'était dans le before du bon
journal sur canal+ ou deux à trois fois
par semaine vous deviez en fonction de
l'actualité
un raid personnage un peu décalé alors
on peut se demander justement pourquoi
après votre ce passage sur petit et
grand écran vous avez souhaité rejoindre
la scène la scène est venue avant avant
avant canal+ mais la scène était une
envie que j'avais depuis depuis tout
petit j'ai toujours voulu monter sur
scène j'écrivais des spectacles à
l'école etc
faut-il cinéma d'abord et puis l'arrivée
à paris et à paris c'était mon rêve
d'écrire spectacle on sait ce que j'ai
fait et en faisant en faisant un
spectacle sur scène finalement canal+ a
pensé à moi pour des personnages et puis
tout s'est un petit peu enchaîné voilà
dans des disciplines différentes mais un
petit peu dans des fours des supports
différents
alors c'est la question qu'on se pose
justement parce que dans toute la
galerie de personnages un peu en marge
un peu anecdotique qui constitue le fil
rouge de votre spectacle
oui est ce que justement ils ont inspiré
ce qu'ils ont été inspirés de vos
personnages que vous présentiez pour le
before du grand journal pas exactement
parce que les les personnages que je
crée pour le before du grand journal
c'est un des personnages qui étaient
créés sur l'actualité principalement du
don qu il y avait 100% d'actualité que
je devais créer des personnages
c'est un peu du sur mesure aussi avec ce
qu'on avait bombay s'est passé ça cette
semaine il ya un rappeur qui sauront
qu'ils seront un album est ce que tu es
capable d'écrire un rap ou voilà c'était
c'était assez amusant à faire parce que
voilà c'était un petit peu dans
l'urgence et sa demande et voilà deux
d'être vifs et d'avoir de la créativité
par rapport par rapport à l'actualité le
spectacle c'est différent parce que
c'est des personnages que j'ai croisé
donc qu'ils sont un petit peu intemporel
qui sont des personnages on peut croiser
tout le temps l'envoi repréciser le
thème justement de ce spectacle donc
c'est s'étire et de votre expérience de
votre vie et ça met en scène toutes les
personnes que vous avez pu rencontrer
lors de votre arrivée en capital
français c'est ça du départ du départ à
bruxelles dans le bistrot j'ai grandi à
bruxelles jusqu'à un petit peu la vie
d'artiste à paris voilà c'est s'aider
des croquis de personnages des
personnages qui m'ont fait rire ou qui
m'ont voilà qui m'ont interpellé quoi il
ya autant de personnages belge que des
clubs français puisque ça démarre à
bruxelles et puis ça se passe à paris
pourquoi justement est ce que vous avez
construit votre spectacle comme ça ça
aurait pu être un one man show voilà
vous vous y évoquer des dix anecdotes
qui vous étaient personnels mais
pourquoi est-ce que vous passez par par
le médium du personnage un peu décalé
parce que j'aime jouer parce que parce
que
j'adore ça et que c'était pour moi ça
s'est fait naturellement je me suis pas
dit est-ce que je vais raconter des
anecdotes ou jouer j'avais envie de
jouer et donc c'est la forme naturelle
capri le spectacle
et
et voilà en fait c'était je trouve que
c'est une belle forme aussi c'est
intéressant les personnages puisque ça
transmet un petit peu la vis aux six
autres autant que je le raconte et
finalement c'est intéressant chanceux
attention ça me rend dingue hein tous
ces artistes qui volettent belge quoi
alors que moi je fais tout pour être
français
je joue en france je bois du vin j'ai eu
au testing deux mois une expression qui
m'a halluciné très tôt c'est
l'expression quand tu rencontres une
fixer les mecs dit souvent excuses et
mademoiselle c'est possible d'avoir
votre 0,6 j'aime et j'ai cela en
belgique à bruxelles
parce que c'est moi mademoiselle c'est
possible d'après 0 472
bonjour et bienvenue chez jean-claude be
queen tu viens de belgique
j'adore la belgique j'adore les belles
chanteuses est gentil vous aimez faire
là vous avez un personnage auquel vous
tenez particulièrement dans ce spectacle
ou pas oui il ya un personnage en boîte
de nuit et qui étrangement le personnage
que j'ai pas croiser quelques est
vraiment le plus créé imaginé cette
chimie un mec en boîte un petit peu
perdues j'aime beaucoup
et pourquoi justement est-ce que visite
mais particulière parce qu'il est fou et
parce que le public que le l'apprécient
beaucoup nous disent souvent les films
dispute à un sommet qu un petit peu
idiot un petit peu fou on a tous déjà
croisé en bois denis le mec l'ourcq
irrite ses propres blagues qui drague
lourdement
c'est un personnage qui parle à tout le
monde
oui j'ai l'impression en tout cas
souvent souvent les filles après le
spectacle disputait à ce mec là on a
déjà tous croisés alors ce spectacle
vous l'avez intitulé liberté pour vous
le fait d'arriver sur paris s'était
enfin la liberté
c'était double liberté c'était la mienne
de pouvoir me dire bon ben voila j'ai
envie d'être comédien je joue et
et c'est forcément la liberté du
comédien de pouvoir jouer son spectacle
et la liberté de tous les personnages
qui sont dans ce spectacle sont des
personnages relativement triste ou seul
et donc c'est leur liberté aussi d'un
petit peu raconté thomas qui parle
beaucoup mais on pourrait quand on sent
qu'ils sont restée seule donc c'est
double liberté je voulais un mot j'avais
envie d'appeler spectacle par un mot
donc voilà c'est un mot que je trouve
très beau et qu'est-ce qui vous définit
justement le mieux le drame la comédie
un mélange des deux voilà d'essayer
d'avoir cette liberté sur laquelle on
revient toujours de d'être libre
justement de pouvoir aller là on
peut-être nous attend pas ou d'aller là
j'ai pas jamais jamais j'aime bien c'est
ce que jamais dans l'exercice justement
sur le before c'était de prendre des
risques pas debout mains est un
personnage que je connais je fais le
même toute annonce et chercher bon on va
prendre des risques si l' on ne connaît
pas on va le tester on va le créer
maintenant les projets c'est pareil
quand on est face à un nouveau film un
nouveau scénario manens lancé par ses
rôles là on n'a jamais jamais joué mais
c'est pour ça qu'on est comédien si pour
jouer des rôles c'est pour toujours joué
la même chose de très intéressant et
pourquoi est-ce que vous teniez
justement à ce passage par paris
qu'est ce que ça représente doivent vous
paris c'est un rêve déjà j'avais envie
de déjà faisait 18 ans que j'étais à
bruxelles j'avais envie de bouger de
rencontrer d'autres gens et
j'ai pas il y avait un petit peu ce
fantasme artistique de la bohème tu pars
avec ton sac
c'était pour moi la paris c'était la
ville de la ville deux des comédiens la
ville du jco ne touchez pas j'avais
envie de voir ce que c'était quoi
j'avais envie de je suis pas déçu merci
merci mon frère vers google d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et donc on
pourra vous retrouver vendredi et samedi
prochain 15 et 16 avril à la royale
factory de versailles avec grand plaisir
et l'on ouvre tout de suite une page
sculpture avec catherine atta bonsoir
bonsoir
alors vous êtes adjointe au maire
déléguée à la culture de
voisins-le-bretonneux et vous venez nous
présenter la 7e édition de la biennale
de la ville présenté jusqu'à dimanche 17
avril à la maison de covile la première
question qu'on peut tout de suite se
poser c'est pourquoi avoir souhaité
dédier une biennale entièrement la
sculpture parce que c'est un art assez
méconnu souvent les expositions mêle à
la fois peinture et sculpture c'est très
rare de trouver des expositions
entièrement dédié à la sculpture et nous
trouvons que c'est un
un art qui méritent d'être mis en valeur
et d'investir cette même maison tout en
entier alors il ya 45 artistes qui sont
représentés ils présentent 119 oeuvre il
ya aussi bien des professionnels que des
amateurs tout à fait donc nous faisons
appel à toutes les bonnes volontés nous
commençons à voir énormément énormément
d'artistes qui veulent venir ce propos
pour l'instant nous ne faisons pas de
sélection il se peut que nous soyons
amenés en fait les années futures mais
nous tenons à ce que chaque chaque
personne qui a envie d'exposer puisse
puisse exposer au moins une ou deux
heures
alors on veut retrouver différentes
techniques et aussi bien de la taille
que de la soudure de l'assemblage du
modelage on voit vraiment tous les
matériaux sont à peu près travailler
aussi bien le métal le bronze fil de fer
cristal de synthèse pierre bois et
textile il ya trois coups déjà qu'ils
ont été décerné un prix du jury c'était
pour le rendez-vous de frédéric marqué
deux prix spéciaux du jury également
pour aller aux russes de ghislain de
l'usso et feu sacré de christophe renaud
qui composent ce jury et quels ont été
les critères de sélection alors c'est un
jury qui est très éclectique puisqu'il
est composé à la fois début donc
moi-même et la conseillère en charge de
la culture ainsi que de représentants
trois représentants de nos conseils de
quartier et quatre artistes en fête qui
sont soit des anciens lauréats de
biennale de peinture de sculpture des
artistes plasticiens ou des musiciens
qui oeuvrent dans la commune or une ce
qui a précédé au choix se fut un choix
très démocratique puisque nous avions
tous des oeuvres à choisir des points
alors attribué donc on a chacun réagit
suivant nous jurait notre ressenti notre
sensibilité
il est évident que les artistes avaient
plus le côté technique
en ligne de mire moi je vous avoue que
j'ai fait au feeling c'est un jury qui
fait miroir un peu justement à la
présentation des artistes on retrouve
également des professionnels
complètement et des amateurs
alors il ya plus de 250 enfants qui ont
pu profiter de cette exposition lors de
sorties scolaires c'est un rendez-vous
vraiment connu du bourg
public les artistes sont d'ailleurs
présents l'après midi pour partager
leurs oeuvres et leur art avec le public
à voisins-le-bretonneux vraiment la
culture n'est pas accessoire
non tout à fait on pense que la culture
doit être à la portée de tous
particulièrement à la portée de nos
enfants c'est l'avenir et donc nos
enfants et leur accès à la culture doit
doit être une de nos principales
préoccupations et je pense que toutes
ces actions culturelles qui sont portées
par des artistes du territoire ou
d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel ça crée du lien social ça ça
permet aussi de s'évader de notre monde
quotidien qui n'est pas toujours très
très drôle ça permet de réfléchir aussi
donc en effet je pense que c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait essentiel ça nous a
permis aussi de faire un partenariat
avec les itinéraires poétique des 50 ans
ni rin et le club jeune théâtre de
voisins qui en fait ont écrit des poèmes
sur les oeuvres des sculptures acheté
par la ville qui ses poèmes sont sont
sont exposées sur les murs et accompagne
les structures très bien alors merci
catherine ata d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et vous avez donc jusqu'à
dimanche 17 avril pour vous rendre à la
maison de covile et pouvoir profiter de
la 7e édition de la biennale de
voisins-le-bretonneux et on va partir
maintenant sur une autre exposition des
paysages végétaux et urbain entre
abstraction et figuration
ce sont les oeuvres que propose bertrand
flachau à la mezzanine de l'hôtel de
ville de guyancourt jusqu'au 7 mai ce
photographe plasticien travail en
juxtaposant plusieurs prises de vues
afin d'unifier la base photographique
avec le geste du dessin urbain ou
végétales abstrait ou figuratif les
paysages de bertrand flachau entrouvre
la porte d'un imaginaire et une volonté
de réinventer le monde en une image
complexe et inédite
diplômé de l'école nationale les arts
décoratifs l'artiste crée des oeuvres à
la frontière de deux expressions
plastiques celle de la photographie est
celle du dessin c'est beaucoup de liens
intimes
quand on connaît l'histoire d'un
bertrand plat chaud on se rend compte
que tous ces lieux qui photographient ce
sont des lieux qui pour lui ont une
mémoire qui ont une histoire
il ya un côté effectivement abstrait
figurait
en même temps il ya un côté où on peut
s'évader on peut se laisser porter par
les lignes de l'artiste ou alors on peut
être très concret en garderont seulement
les paysages et finalement faire
abstraction de les dessins chacun y voit
un peu ce qui se fait à l'aide d'une
tablette graphique
bertrand flash au sublime ses
photographies numériques
il peut aussi retravailler directement
ses photographies argentiques par le
dessin au crayon une façon d'associer un
instant réel figer un dessin qui peut se
prolonger à l'infini
c'est un artiste qui s'appuie sur des
photographies qu'il prend les mêmes des
photographies de paysages de forêts de
bois mais aussi des photographies de
paris et après ils retravaillent
entièrement sa photographie avec du
dessin mais travaille avec sa tablette
graphique et sa tablette numérique pour
pouvoir sublimer les dessins donc
effectivement on est dans une technique
qui est plutôt original et plutôt actuel
bertrand flachau expose ses
photographies plastiques à la mezzanine
de l'hôtel de ville de guyancourt
jusqu'au 7 mai prochain et on va parler
désormais de théâtre et de théâtre à
domicile même avec nos invités avec moi
en plateau 2010 on chante alpes et ninon
et catherine germain bonsoir à vous
trois alors vous jouer partout en france
surtout dans les yvelines et vous jouez
chez chez les autres
chez les gens va commencer avec vous
chantal bénino vous avez mis en scène
bleu caramel qui est le spectacle que
vous venez nous présenter pourquoi avoir
opté pour ce choix artistique de la
représentation à domicile alors en fait
historiquement on avait d'abord un
spectacle avec catherine qu'on avait
préparé très classiquement on avait un
texte et mise en scène une comédienne et
on avait préparé ça pour pour le théâtre
et puis les choses je vous raconte pas
touche c'est qu'on n'a pas de beaucoup
enfin les choses ont fait que on s'y
retrouvait à le jouer chez l'habitant on
en est maintenant une soixantaine de
représentations et d'une part c'était
bien pour le spectacle mais on s'est
aperçu que toute la soirée
c'était vraiment quelque chose de très
fortes avec les gens ils sont en
proximité en intimité avec le comédien
et ils ont le temps après d'en parler de
dire venir on passe vraiment toute la
soirée ensemble c'est plus de partage il
ya ça d'une part et c'est une autre
manière d'aborder
d'aborder le spectacle est donc et puis
la faveur on va dire de ça on a la force
d'aller chez les gens dans les maisons
les appartements et tout ça on s'est
aperçu à quel point c'était important le
fait d'être chez quelqu'un et donc c'est
là qu'on a eu l'idée du spectacle
suivant en sachant que celui là on le
jour est chez l'habitant ont prolongé ce
travail là le thème d'ailleurs en fait
moi la voile amis vous a été inspiré
ceux de ses différentes représentations
donc c'est un spectacle construit autour
d'un thème un peu universelle qui parle
à tout le monde il est question d'un
couple à bord dans la soixantaine proche
de la retraite les enfants sont grands
peut-être partie de la maison et donc ce
couple se retrouve un peu face à lui
face à son histoire et s'interroge on
regarde tout de suite un extrait changer
à chaque fois qu'on doit prendre de
décision d compris tout recréer fais moi
confiance ça va bien je me demande si je
vais pas me plaindre les chevaux disons
vous vous êtes comédiens on a pu le voir
dans cet extrait est ce que c'est plus
facile d'aborder des questions qui
touchent le quotidien des gens lorsqu'on
fait du théâtre à domicile
alors c'est entièrement différent aussi
une telle proximité du public que on
peut enfin très souvent on interpelle en
fait le public
il ya un moment de convivialité après où
il nous dit ben voilà on s'est reconnus
parce qu'on s'est aussi posé cette
question là où cette situation s'est
trouvée c est dans le moment qui des
changes qui après le raid est-ce qu'il
était important lorsqu'on est chez les
gens vraiment d'aborder un thème qui
peut être partagée par les autres
oui parce que bon d'abord on est chez
les gens on partage leur leur décor
change de décor à chaque représentation
on s'approprie un petit peu les objets
des bibelots les bibelots des gens et on
se retrouve donc tous ensemble à la fois
dans le décor à la faune ont des
préoccupations et dans le thème partager
alors justement catherine
comment est ce que vous prenez
possession de l'environnement de vos
hôtes mais on a une petit rituel on
arrive à peu près trois heures avant
chez les gens de façon à découvrir les
lieux qui sont souvent complètement
différent on joue dans des bons titres
pièce grande pièce salle à manger salon
voilà on veut arriver suffisamment la
vence pour prendre possession du lieu
justement pour cent pour le sentir et
pour positionner notre canapé nos petits
objets nos petites tables basses tout
fin tout ce qui va nous aider à jouer
et puis voilà on s'imprègne du lieu et
on a toujours aussi l'habitude de faire
une allemande ce qu'on appelle c'est à
dire on se refait tout le texte avec les
déplacements qui selon les
configurations des appartements change
tout le temps il ya des sorties qui se
font à coup des fois jardin on a besoin
de refaire tout le texte avec les
nouveaux positionnements et ça nous
permet de voilà de refaire notre
histoire nos liens dans ce nouveau lieu
le fait de s'approprier les objets c'est
pour que les gens puissent se projeter
plus facilement dans le spectacle ben on
a envie de faire vrai de de créer de la
vérité on arrive chez les gens et c'est
plus chez les gens c'est chez nous ça
devient votre selle devienne notre scène
dans sa note
utilisons nous le disait donc il ya un
vent un temps de partage derrière une
forme de restitution de partage de
retour sur sur l'expérience que vous
faites avec vos hôtes la différence pour
un comédien entre une représentation sur
scène ou à domicile
elle se fait ou pour vous sans talent
effectivement dans le jeu du comédien il
ya une grande différence
ils sont vraiment ils font un travail
vraiment sur la la proximité l'intimité
et on avait eu comme ça une très belle
réflexion une fois c'était aux
spectacles précédents catherine dent
alors là vraiment le lieu était
absolument minuscule devait y avoir dix
personnes toutes assez et à la fin il y
avait une dame qui avait dit on n'a pas
pu vous applaudir on avait l'impression
d'être à l'intérieur de vous laisse
penser pas c'est pas toujours proche à
ce point là mais il ya effectivement les
gens nous parlent beaucoup ils disent
mais c'est nous on est en miroir et
effectivement ils sont ils sont vraiment
chez les deux personnages en question
cela doit être assez saisissant et s'est
déroulé une expérience à découvrir
alors merci à vous trois justement de
nous avoir fait partager le théâtre à
domicile qui n'est pas encore peut-être
assez connu du grand public et donc pour
vous contacter est programmée une
représentation à domicile du spectacle
bleus carmel vous pouvez contacter le
numéro qui s'affiche à l'écran et on va
parler de sculpture à nouveau plus que
quelques jours pour profiter de
l'exposition d'isabelle daucourt mignon
conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux 7 céramiste installée à
saint-amand-en-puisaye berceau de la
poterie exposé 80 pièces si la tendance
est à ne voir généralement que le côté
utilitaire de la poterie et de la
céramique
l'exposition vous permettra de voir
comment il est possible de magnifier
cette pratique par la porcelaine et le
travail de l'émail
son travail est très particulier par sa
technique sans rentrer dans des détails
très précis c'est vrai que tout ce qui
va être le travail de l'émail est un
petit peu compliqué parce que c'est des
procédés chimiques avec des phénomènes
de réduction d'oxydation dans les fora
flammes mais elle elle va vraiment être
dans ce travail chimiques dans la
recherche de la couleur c'est pour ça
que vous avez énormément de déchet de
rouge de gauche très profond de rouge de
cuivre de rouge carmin de rouge qui vont
tirer vers le violet c'est une vraie
recherche sur la couleur
et l'on poursuit maintenant avec notre
rubrique cinéma tout de suite vos
réactions sur les nouveautés à la fiche
de ce mercredi 13 avril
c'est un excellent film qui se passe
dans un désert en fin de compte avec des
scènes assez assez forte mais c'est
peut-être pas à voir avec tout public
mais en tous les cas on a beaucoup aimé
ce film chasse entre leurs hommes va
dire mais un peu hein pas semblable sur
beaucoup de points donc le voilà assez
déçu ça sera vraiment du schéma
classique de tout va bien dans le
meilleur des mondes et c'est ça qui est
appréciable aujourd'hui dans les films
c'est qu'on retrouve un peu une part de
deux réalités très très très bien ça se
suit de bout en bout c'est du lard tu
extraordinaire et c'est passionnant
visiblement serviable seller chez ses
propres les combats d'animaux
bien honnêtement c'est dur
j'essaie défi c'est c'est eh bien il n'y
avait pas une cenne n'y avait personne
comme dans certains films
elle a été bien et 7e art toujours
battre en pilier du cinéma les yeux
d'elsa de saint-cyr-l'ecole vous
présente le festival play it again
le coup de coeur des yeux d'elsa cette
semaine c'est un festival que nous
hébergeons pour la deuxième année
consécutive le festival play it again
c'est un festival de cinéma de
patrimoine les films d'hier dans les
salles d'aujourd'hui c'est le slogan
c'est un festival qui se passe sur toute
la france et les salles le souhaitant
s'associe avec des distributeurs pour
mettre en avant certains films 15 films
en l'occurrence de leur catalogue
alors dans la zone de saint quentin il
ya là le cinéma le grenier à sel à
trappes qui participent et puis nous au
cinéma les yeux d'elsa de saint cyr
l'école pour nous notre programmation on
a choisi deux films français l'eau à la
bouche de jacques doniol valcroze un
film de 59
et puis
une aussi longue absence film de henri
colpi avec alida valli henry wilson qui
avait une palme d'or en 61 mais on a
aussi choisi un troisième film qui va
nous permettre de poursuivre notre
travail de 6 des conférences autour des
films des années 80 on avait diffusé
blade runner on a diffusé ce signe de
john carpenter et là on va diffuser
encore un film emblématique des années
80 il s'agit de rambo avec sylvester
stallone un film de ted kotcheff j'aurai
le plaisir de le présenter le vendredi
15 avril
ce vendredi et puis vous en dire un peu
plus sur ce film alors évidemment il
s'agit de la grande histoire très connu
et ce personnage rambo le tout premier
qui est vraiment un film à re découvrir
sur grand écran on en a souvent une
image un peu galvaudé c'est un film
beaucoup plus intéressant que ce qu'il
n'y paraît et avant de nous quitter tout
de suite un agenda culturel pour votre
fin de semaine vous pourrez retrouver
mickey 3d jeudi soir 14 avril 20h à la
batterie de guyancourt dans un univers
pop électro et rock
entre souvenirs
souviendra du chou
vous savez la tête
sous les roues
avec lui
or
il se souvient
l'histoire ne nous a pas eu assez
et rendez vous vendredi soir 21h au
prisme d'elancourt pour retrouver la
chanteuse oum et son dernier album arabi
l'écriture de cet album a été inspirée
des tournées de la chanteuse marocaine
et de son identité plurielle
oh
là
et c'est la fin de votre émission
culturelle vous pourrez la voir et la
revoir sur notre site internet je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine et vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée